[Musique]
le harcèlement sexuel après le temps de
la parole celui de l'action alors qu'une
enquête a été ouverte lundi après une
plainte contre le député de la
république en marche christophe hareng
l'assemblée nationale à son tour décidé
de monter au créneau des affiches ont
fait leur apparition dans les ascenseurs
un rappel de la loi pour les
législateurs caroline ninkov légendaire
véronique borel et anis recoller
nul n'est censé ignorer la loi et
surtout pas les députés pourtant
aujourd'hui placardées dans les
ascenseurs de l'assemblée ces
affichettes reproduisent en deux
articles du code pénal sur le
harcèlement sexuel et moral un rappel
qui intervient avec alors que plusieurs
signalements sont en cours à l'assemblée
depuis plusieurs semaines les
témoignages d'assistante parlementaire
affluent
cette ancienne collaboratrice par le
même d'une liste noire de parlementaires
qui circulait entre collaboratrice parce
qu'on savait que fallait pas prendre
l'ascenseur avec eux c'est quoi parce
que y'a faire un geste qui vous colle
union fait ce qu'il y avait des
histoires et donc il y avait une black
list des mecs avec qui il fallait pas
trop prendre de risques
l'un de ces députés incriminés juge
malgré tout cette campagne d'affichage
assez inutile le combat qui a été engagé
par les femmes j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire je ne sais pas dans cette attitude
mais
est naturel et légitime
c'est pas la peine maintenant du jour un
domaine de nous à mettre partout de
placardées partout le président de
l'assemblée nationale défend la
nécessité d'agir au sein du palais
bourbon où comme partout les
comportements doivent changer
sur ce sujet grave difficile du
harcèlement eh bien il faut se donner
tous les moyens que l'on peut avoir bien
sûr du point de vue de la justice mais
aussi dans un lieu de travail comme
l'assemblée nationale chez les députés
les avis sont partagés il faut pas
stigmatiser le palais bobos comme étant
un lieu où on agresse et on harcèle plus
les femmes qu ailleurs pas puisque
ailleurs moi je vais vous dire depuis je
suis dépité ça m'est jamais arrivé alors
que dans le milieu de l'entreprise où je
n'ai avant ça m'était arrivé donc
arrêtons stigmatiser les députés ça
permet aussi de mettre le doigt sur des
réalités qu'il faut dénoncer face auquel
il faut se mettre en ordre de bataille
d'une certaine façon le président de
l'assemblée prévient que l'immunité des
députés seraient levés en cas d'obstacle
à la justice dans le cadre d'affaires de
harcèlement
[Musique]